RoBoHon is a robot that doubles as a smartphone.
Or is it a smartphone that doubles as a robot?
Either way, it comes from Japan's Sharp...
...and a country that has brought us just about every crazy robot we've ever seen.
The cute RoBoHon stands just 20 centimeters...
...and will go on sale in Japan in the first half of 2016.
The robot has a camera, an LCD screen, a microphone, speaker,...
...and voice recognition system.
There's also a projector in its head for you to play movies or display images.
In a demonstration at the CEATEC electronics show outside of Tokyo,...
...the robot responded to instructions to place a call, take a picture,...
...display that picture through a projector and dance.